[Musique]
est historique est sans précédent un
impressionnant qu'on voit campagne
l'ancien président des États-Unis obligé
de comparer devant le Tribunal fédéral
de Miami dès qu'il franchit le seuil du
palais de justice il est en état
d'arrestation après la prise de ses
empreintes digitales il est resté les
bras croisés sans dire un mot rapporte
des témoins dans la salle c'est son
avocat tote blanche qui appelait des non
coupable pour les 37 chefs d'incubation
devant le jugement d'un autre champ est
accusé en trop d'avoir mis la sécurité
du pays en péril lorsqu'il a quitté la
Maison Blanche en conservant des
documents confidentiels dont des secrets
militaires on lui reproche d'avoir
refusé de les restituer malgré les
injonctions judiciaires entre à
judiciaire faux témoignages
[Applaudissements]
et pour ces partisans dans notre champ
des victimes d'une supercherie
judiciaire pour l'empêcher de remporter
les élections présidentielles
sont sur qui vivent on craint des
débordements dans le centre-ville de
Miami avance sa comparution fidèle à ses
habitudes dans notre chambre écrit sur
le réseau social truth social je vais
nommer un procureur spécial pour
poursuivre Joe byden et critique le
président le plus corrompu de l'histoire
et toutes ses familles criminelles qui
détruisent nos élections nos frontières
et tout le pays devant le palais de
justice quelques centaines de partisans
je suis venu de Nashville au Tennessee
dit-elle juste pour soutenir dans notre
chambre mais ce New York est en petite
chambre des tonnes dans le paysage
c'est un culte dit-il c'est comme Hitler
d'un autre champ est un escroc
les esprits s'échauffent
parmi les chefs d'accusation plusieurs
qui violeraient la loi sur l'espionnage
un crime passible de dix années de
prison
il dit qu'il a le droit de posséder ces
documents dit-il je ne sais pas si c'est
exact
après moins d'une heure de comparution
dans notre chambre quitte le palais de
justice devant une foule en liesse
tout un anniversaire dit-il à la veille
de ses 77 ans aux réputé café Versailles
dans la petite Havane à Miami
c'est un pays corrompu dit-il en déclin
dans notre chambre prend donc sa
campagne électorale et si l'image qu'il
veut que ses partisans retiennent de
cette journée historique ici